[Music]
thank you
one important theme of Philip K Dick's
alternate history novel The Man in the
High Castle is that of historicity of
artifacts they're authenticity because
as it's going to turn out within the
occupied Pacific States of America and
really within the Japanese co-prosperity
civilization as a whole there's an
interest a very strong interest in
Americana and it could be that they have
a greater interest in artifacts of the
peoples that they have conquered more
globally but we don't actually learn
that and everything is happening in the
former United States of America so the
Japanese Elites turn out to be very
interested in collecting things that
they feel
convey something about the spirit of the
American ends whether as they call it
the aboriginals meaning the Native
Americans or the settlers and and you
know military people and we could go on
and on and on and we've got this uh
character who's introduced at the very
start Robert childon
he has a shop that caters specifically
to this and I think we should begin with
him and we're actually in some respect
and end with him as well in looking at
this so he's had this shop now for only
four years and we find out four years
ago children had not been the dealer in
the rare and desirable which he was now
he'd operated a second uh small rather
dimly lighted secondhand Bookshop on
Geary his neighboring stores sold used
furniture hardware did laundry it was
not a nice neighborhood and then he says
into this District of the city had come
an elderly Japanese ex-army man a major
Ito humo tall slender white-haired
walking and standing stiffly the major
had given children his first inkling of
what might be done with his line of
merchandise
I am a collector major humo had
explained he'd spent an entire afternoon
searching among the heaps of old
magazines in the story in his mild voice
he'd explain something which children
could not quite grasp at the time to
many wealthy cultured Japanese so the
elites the historic objects of American
popular civilization were of equal
interest alongside the more formal
antiques why this was so the major
himself did not know he was particularly
addicted to the collecting of old
magazines dealing with U.S brass buttons
as well as the buttons itself themselves
it was on the order of coin or stamp
collecting no rational explanation could
ever be given and high prices were being
paid by wealthy collectors so let's
pause on that for just a sec before we
go into this great vignette that
illustrates how the idea is forming in
children's mind
we see that dick has thought out that
there has to be a demand in order for
the supply to make sense and we're going
to see that this is going to lead to
supply of both authentic artifacts and
to because there's money to be made in
this
fake artifacts as well so going on with
this the major says I'll give you an
example do you know what is meant by
horrors of War cards
children had at last recalled the cards
had been dispensed during his childhood
with bubble gum assent at peace there
had been a series of them each card
depicting a different horror a dear
friend of mine the major godan collects
horrors of War he lacks but one now the
sinking of the penne he has offered a
substantial sum of money for that
particular card
now here we see an important transition
flip cards children children had said
suddenly sir we flipped them there was a
head and a tail side on each card he'd
been about eight years old each of us
had a pack of flip cards we stood two of
us facing each other each of us dropped
a card so it flipped in the air the boy
whose card landed with the head side up
the side of the picture won both cards
how enjoyable to recall those good days
the early happy days of his childhood
considering major humo had said I have
heard my friend discuss his horrors of
War cards and he has never mentioned
this it is my opinion he does not know
how these cards were actually put to use
eventually the majors friend had shown
up at the store to hear children's
historically first-hand account notice
historically firsthand right the man a
retired officer of the Imperial Army had
been fascinated
bottle caps children had exclaimed
without warning the Japanese blinked
uncomprehendingly we used to collect the
tops from milk bottles as kids the round
tops that gave the name of the dairy
there must have been thousands of
dairies in the United States each one
printed a special top
the officer's eyes had glinted with the
Instinct do you possess any of your
sometime collections sir naturally
children did not but probably it was
still possible to obtain the ancient
long forgotten tops from the days before
the war when milk had come in glass
bottles rather than throw away
pasteboard cartons and so by stages he
had gotten into the business
others opened similar places taking
advantage of the ever-growing Japanese
craze for Americana but children had
always kept his Edge so we see here the
story of how this new business
arises right and so that that's quite
important now historicity is a key part
of this for the clients for the
collectors who want this Americana they
want authenticity if possible they want
to know the Providence where things have
actually come from and we get a really
interesting discussion of this in uh
Windham
um
Matson who is in the business of
producing fakes as we're going to see in
just a bit
um and he's talking to his mistress Rita
and he says this
um this whole damn historicity business
is nonsense the Japs are bats I'll prove
it getting up he heard into his study
returned it once with two cigarette
lighters which he sat down on the coffee
table look at these look the same don't
they well listen one has historicity in
it he grinned at her pick them up go
ahead one's worth maybe forty fifty
thousand dollars on the collector's
Market the girl picked up the two
lighters and examined them do you feel
it he kitted her the historicity and she
says well what's historicity he says
when a thing has history in it listen
one of those two Zippo lighters was in
Franklin D Roosevelt's pocket when he
was assassinated and one wasn't one has
historicity a hell of a lot of it as
much as any object ever had and one has
nothing
Can you feel it he nudged her you can't
you can't tell which is which there's no
mystical plasmic presence no Aura around
it gee the girl said odd is it really
true that he had one of these on him
that day
sure and I know which it is you see my
point it's all a big racket they're
playing it on themselves I mean a gun
goes through a famous battle like the
Moose argon and it's the same as if it
hadn't unless you know it's in here he
tapped his head in the mind not in the
gun I used to be a collector in fact
that's how I got into this business I
collected stamps early British colony
and so he goes on suppose say last year
the Canadian government or somebody
finds the plates from which some old
stamp was printed and the ink and a
supply of and the girl says I don't
believe either these two lighters belong
to Franklin Roosevelt and Windham Matson
says that's my point I'd have to prove
it to you with some sort of document a
paper of authenticity and so it's all
fake a mass delusion the paper proves
it's worth not the object itself
show me the paper she says sure hopping
up he made his way back into the study
from the wall he took the Smithsonian
institutions framed certificate the
paper and the lighter it cost him a
fortune but they were worth it because
they enabled him to prove that he was
right the word fake meant nothing really
since the word authentic meant nothing
really and so this is a you know very
important explanation about what's going
on with this entire historicity thing
and so this leads us then to the
business of producing fake artifacts and
we come back to uh the the corporation
WM Corporation state of legal business
consisted in turning out wrought iron
staircases railings fireplaces and
ornaments all on a mass basis from
standard designs but it maintained
another business from which it's real
profits were derived using an elaborate
variety of tools materials and machines
WM Corporation turned out a constant
flow of forgeries
of pre-war American artifacts these
forgeries were cautiously but expertly
fed into the wholesale Art Mart object
Market to join the genuine objects
collected through the continent as in
the stamp and coin business no one could
possibly estimate the percentage of
forgeries in circulation and no one
especially the dealers and the
collectors themselves wanted to and we
see Frank Frank is there working on a
cult revolver of the frontier period he
had made the molds himself done the
casting and had been busy hand smoothing
the pieces there was an unlimited market
for small arms of the American Civil War
and Frontier period WM Corporation could
sell all that Frank could turn out it
was his specialty and so uh you know we
read a little bit more another three
days and the gun would be finished yes
he thought it was good work an expert
could have told the difference but the
Japanese collectors weren't authorities
in the proper sense had no standards or
tests by which to judge in fact as far
as he knew it had never occurred to them
to ask themselves if the soul-called
historic art objects for sale in West
Coast shops are genuine perhaps someday
they would and then the bubble would
burst the market would collapse even for
the authentic pieces a gresham's law The
Fakes would undermine the value of the
real and that no doubt was the motive
for the failure to investigate after all
everybody was happy so very interesting
situation that is developed within just
you know the space of half of a a decade
right and then we get this very
interesting incident
um Frank as we find out later we have
just um the man
goes into children's shop and this is
because he's trying to essentially set
up his own business by blackmailing his
former boss Linda Matson and he's going
to inquire specifically about Civil War
pistols and he goes in posing as an
admiral's gentleman of a ship that has
not uh you know sailed for 15 years
because it's at the bottom of the ocean
and then he asked to see he wants 12
pieces
and he says he's going to examine some
of them here and he's going to pay in
advance
and so he looks at a Colt 44 from 1860
he examines it and then lifting his eyes
he says sir this is an imitation this
piece is no older than six months your
offering is a fake I am cast into Gloom
see the wood here artificially aged by
an acid chemical what a shame children
can't believe it and Frank says it's an
imitation of the authentic historic gun
nothing more I am afraid sir you have
been deceived perhaps by some
unscrupulous churl you must report this
to the San Francisco police it Grieves
me you may have other imitations too in
your shop is it possible sir that you
the owner dealer in such items cannot
distinguish the forgeries from the real
and this sends children into all sorts
of worries and frantic activity he's
going to demand that the supplier absorb
the cost and take back the weapon and
this is going to send reverberations
through the supply chain we also find
out that children is going to like sort
of obsess about what is this gentleman's
motive is he from a rival shop trying to
undermine children's confidence and make
him waste time perhaps resources what is
actually going on here and of course
children has to largely keep this to
himself because he doesn't want any you
know news of this spreading
I mentioned the reverberations in the
supply chain so this is chapter five the
telephone call from Ray Calvin who's the
middleman puzzled Windham Matson he
cannot make sense of it Calvin said look
here my friend we're sending back that
whole last shipment from you people and
I'd send back stuff before that we've
paid for everything except the last
shipment they're lousy fakes
and then when to Manson says but but you
knew that I mean Ray you've always been
aware of the situation and then Calvin
says this I knew they were fakes I'm not
talking about that I'm talking about the
lousy part I'm not really concerned
whether some gun you sent us really was
used in the Civil War or not all I care
about it is that it's a satisfactory
Colt 44 item whatever it is in your
catalog it has to meet
standards so it's got to be able to fool
people right so this this business of
producing Fakes fakes they they lack the
authenticity they lack the Providence
they lack the historicity
but they got to be able to fool people
now we have one other thing to to talk
about with this important theme and
that's a transition away from worrying
about Americana historical artifacts and
the opportunity to do something more and
this comes about through children's
engagement with this very interesting
young hip Japanese couple the kasuras
who've now been stationed indefinitely
in the United States and that's actually
in the very first chapter but what we
see very importantly happening a bit
later on is children is invited by Paul
and Betty kasura to their very home and
there's going to be a lot of interesting
stuff happening there
he enters and he sees so ascetic few
pieces of lamp here table bookcase print
on the wall the incredible Japanese
sense of Wabi the ability to find in
simple objects of Beauty Beyond that of
the elaborate or ornate something we're
going to talk about elsewhere and we see
that there's sort of a mixture of
Japanese very modern Japanese and
Americana stuff going on and so children
brings out a
artifact to provide them with he brought
out small tissue paper wrap thing he
laid it discreetly on the low table both
of them immediately noticed and this
required him to say bag it's hell for
you to display fragment of the
relaxation and enjoyment I feel in being
here his hand opened the tissue paper
showing them the gift bit of ivory
carved a century ago by Whalers from New
England tiny ornamented art object
called the scrimshaw their faces
illuminated with knowledge of the
scrimshaws which the old Sailors had
made in their spare time no single thing
could have summed up old U.S culture
more so this winds up being a very very
suitable gift right one that does have
historicity for them and then we noticed
that you know Paul is going to try to
show off some of his stuff including
um you know Dixieland Jazz and and other
records and they eventually to get into
discussions about politics so I'm going
to pass over that
then what we find is
Frank interestingly is going to be the
designer of some new jewelry pieces that
are being sold on consignment in Robert
children's shop and Paul is gifted one
of these to pass on to his wife he
doesn't pass it on to his wife as we're
going to see and there's a whole
interesting discussion about that but
children
realizes something this worry about the
fakes
isn't a problem for this new jewelry
that is going to sell
here we go there was another notion
circulating and growing in the back of
Robert children's mind with these
there's no problem of authenticity and
that problem May someday wreck the
historic American artifex industry not
today or tomorrow but after that
who knows
he thinks if I quietly build up a stock
of non-historic objects contemporary
work with no historicity either real or
imagined
I might find I have the edge over the
competition as long as it isn't costing
me anything
so this is where he gets the idea to
gift it to Betty kasura and then uh he
is with Paul talking with him about this
and what we find is that Paul has
realized there's there's something about
the jewelry that's being sold in Robert
Sheldon's shop made by Frank Frank and
it involves no Wabi
no historicity but instead
which again we'll talk about a little
bit more before and he says
um
I have come to identify the value which
this has in opposition to historicity I
am deeply moved as you may see to have
no historicity and also no artistic
aesthetic worth and yet to partake of
some ethereal value that is a Marvel
right and so he says an entire new world
is being pointed to by this uh we lack a
word for an object like this it is an
authentically new thing on the face of
the world children thinks to himself
authentic yes it certainly is I catch
that notion but as to the rest and so
this is where we get into another entire
discussion so we see a very interesting
we could say resolution at least for
children
about how to get out of this trap of
historicity something of value that
nobody really knows that can only be you
might say manufactured right but it's
not something that should be
manufactured except being manufactured
way back then so very interesting we
could call it subplot or theme running
through this work and motivating quite a
few of the characters and their choices
and actions